as a warm-up towards finding the
distribution of a function of random
variables let us start by considering
the discrete case so let X be a discrete
random variable and let Y be defined as
a given function of X we know the PMF of
X and wish to find the PMF of Y here is
a simple example the random variable X
takes the values 2 3 4 and 5 with the
probabilities given in the failure and Y
is the function indicated here then for
example the probability that Y takes a
value of 4 this is also the value of the
PMF of Y evaluated at 4 this is simply
the sum of the probabilities of the
possible values of X that give rise to a
value of y that is equal to 4 therefore
this expression is equal to the
probability that x equals to 4 plus the
probability that X is equal to 5 or in
PMF notation we can write it in this
manner and in this numerical example it
would be 0.3 plus 0.4 more generally for
any given value of little Y the
probability that the random variable
capital y takes this particular value is
the sum of the probabilities of the
little X that result in that particular
value so the probability that the random
variable capital y which is the same as
G of X takes on a specific value is the
sum of the probabilities of all possible
values of little X where we only
consider those values of little X that
give rise to the specific value little Y
that were interested in let us now look
into the special case where we have a
linear function of a discrete random
variable
suppose that X is described by the PMF
shown in this diagram and let us
consider the random variable Z which is
defined as two times X we would like to
plot the PMF of Z first let us note the
values that Z can take when X is equal
to minus 1 Z is going to be equal to
minus 2 when X is equal to 1 Z is going
to be equal to 2 and when X is equal to
2 Z is going to be equal to 4 this event
that X is equal to minus 1 happens with
probability 2 over 6 and when that event
happens Z will take a value of minus 2
so this event happens with probability 2
over 6 with probability 1 6 X takes a
value of 1 so that Z takes a value of 2
and this happens with probability 1 over
6 and finally this last event here
happens with probability 3 over 6 we
have thus found the PMF of Z notice that
it has the same shape as the PMF of X
except that it is stretched or scaled
horizontally by a factor of 2 let us now
consider the random variable Y defined
as 2 X plus 3 or what is the same as Z
plus 3
with probability 2/6 Z is equal to minus
2 and in that case Y is going to be
equal to plus 1 and this event happens
with probability 2 over 6 with
probability 1 over 6 Z takes a value of
2 so that Y takes a value of 5 and
finally with probability 3 over 6 Z
takes a value of 4 so that Y takes a
value of 7
what we see here is that the PMF of Y
has exactly the same shape as the PMF of
Z except that it is shifted to the right
by 3 to summarize in order to find the
PMF of a linear function such as 2x plus
3 what we do is that we first stretch
the PMF of x by a factor of 2 and then
shifted horizontally by 3 we can also
describe the PMF of Y through a formula
for any given value of little Y the PMF
is going to be equal to the probability
that our random variable Y takes on this
specific value little Y then we recall
that Y has been defined in our example
to be equal to 2x plus 3 so we're
looking at the probability of this event
but this is the same as the event that X
takes a value equal to Y minus 3 divided
by 2 and in PMF notation we can write it
in this form so what this is saying is
that the probability that Y takes on a
specific value is the same as the
probability that X takes on some other
specific value and that value here is
that value of x that would give rise to
this particular value little Y now we
can generalize the calculation that we
just did and more generally if we have a
linear function over discrete random
variable X the PMF of the random
variable Y is given by this formula in
terms of the PMF of the random variable
X the derivation is the same we use B
instead of the specific number 3 and we
have a general constant a instead of the
two that we had in this example and this
formula describes exactly what we did
graphically
in our previous example this factor of a
here serves to stretch the PMF by a
factor of a and this term B here serves
to shift the PMF by B